and minimalists s podcast has bad words
hmm hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists before we get
started happy birthday to podcast young
man happy birthday to you happy birthday
to you quick a little camera on Sean
happy birthday happy birthday to you
sorry I can't carry melody with you you
did a great job I was letting you go
that was strong and podcast Sean you're
an Aries is today your actual day no no
the day this comes out how awesome oh
yeah yeah
Taurus Ford Taurus edit he is sort of
the Ford Taurus of podcasting I don't
know what that's a compliment I mean
it's a compliment in this sense of like
he just puts his head down and goes goes
goes there's no stopping him but when I
scatter when his catalytic converter
breaks it's all down real voice you here
with us today if you're just listening
to this and not watching it is Matt
Nathanson we're gonna talk about sadness
today and who better to talk about
sadness with the topic today so we did
the top tackle one topic we don't do
interviews we just answer questions
people like call in for some reason they
ask our advice for stuff and we monitor
on until we cobble together an answer
for people but I wanted to talk to you
about sort of success and sadness and
whether success leads to happiness
whether happiness leads to sadness
whether sadness leads to happiness and I
know we have all the puzzle pieces on
the table you're all and now look what I
have also here on the table it is
something called a compact disc are you
familiar with these yes those had those
back in the back in the 1800s those were
no stop the plague back in my village I
stopped listening to them in the late
eighties yeah but here's the thing we've
been doing this thing called screen love
Saturday
and for a while I was doing completely
screen look so no phone at all and my
wife and I we would just like drive
around get lost in Los Angeles because
you like I don't have GPS now what am I
gonna do and so we went over to amoeba
music and I found your CD literally the
day after it came out which I was just
shocked but I thought I was just gonna
have like my pick between like Third Eye
Blind and like David Gray's white ladder
or something but uh so CDs you just
named two quintessential CD yes well I
did buy the white ladder album the same
day about two albums I bought Matt
Nathanson sings his sad heart which is
his new album you can check it out
everywhere and well here's the thing
Matt you your music is like a book
report on sadness I can't but I feel
like like it's it's like sprinkled to
use a mixed metaphor here yes with with
hope yeah yeah I mean some add hope one
might say yeah you gotta have hope or
it's all it's all bad right if you don't
believe that it can get better or that
you can get better it's all downhill but
yeah definitely a lot of sadness I don't
know what the D I mean I know what the
deal is but I thought I got to the
bottom of it in therapy I spent so much
money in therapy and then I was gonna
make a record that was gonna be like all
anthems yeah I was like people are
unimpaired and they need to feel
powerful I'm gonna make the record to do
that and then I started recording this
record writing songs and the first one
was like why'd you leave me oh my god
that's just one just the debris in the
way of the empowering anthem let's go I
was like don't go by like song 13 I was
like I think we have a thread here I
think I have not gone to the bottom of
my well I think the second song on this
album is way way back and in it it's
like the I wish that it would have been
the opening song because it's like the
best opening line to an album I feel
like what is the last player from the
lifeboat yeah and and it's like it says
so much you Sean and I were just talking
about this before we started recording
how a lot of the best stories or best
songs like all of the action is sort of
taking place to the right of the frame
it but you're alluding to everything
that's sort of happening there at
happening there and so last Flair from
from the lifeboat is is that just says
so much and then you you start to unpack
it quite a bit throughout throughout the
song but I I wrote a review of this
album at the end of each year we put out
a list of like our favorite albums from
from the previous year and so for 2018
this was definitely on the list and I do
like a little one one-line review and
and the thing that I said is it's upbeat
sad songs about heartbreak in the
rearview and I think I think part of
that is sadness says something about
what's going on like what what already
happened and I like it got us to this
this point so it's in the rearview but
somehow you've you've taken this topic
and you've you've made it upbeat there's
this sort of upbeat sadness can you talk
a little bit about that yeah I feel like
I feel like musically I'm a big fan of
when some I'm a super big fan of like
sad sad right when when Conor Oberst
writes a song that just sounds sad and
it is sad yeah I'm sure ru Fitzgerald
fan Ella or what Simmons yeah
Fitzsimmons that's enough it's a William
Fitzsimmons
yeah he's sad sad right when William is
sad like that's what I'm saying so I
respect and love the sad sad for sure
but for me it's a very weird example but
I remember the Gin Blossoms way back in
the day put out their first record and
they had this lyric that was in my
favorite song and I and and I was called
la lost horizons and I didn't really
know the lyrics but the song super poppy
and I'd sing it while I was driving and
the lyric was she had nothing left to
say so she said she loved me and I stood
there grateful for the lie yeah he's
drinking you drink enough of anything to
make this world look new again you know
and I was like whoa and I was like and I
was like that is the way to do it if you
can deliver something that feels one way
but if you unpack it it feels like three
or four layers deeper like to me that's
that's like that's the kind of music I
really like to dig into and so
yeah being me being said like we need
another straight white man being sad on
album like we need to be like like
kicked in the in the in the balls that's
a big group you know I mean I gotta do
it really well man you got to do it here
you got to dig in you got to dig in but
like people like Conor Oberst William
Fitzsimmons those people do sadness
really well in a in a way Leonard Cohen
did sort of he was not as sad but like
there was there was a thing you went to
Leonard Cohen to get a certain thing and
for me I I just liked a little bit more
yeah a little bit more sugar with my
medicine essentially yeah yeah it's fun
I think
and also melodies are so like pop I
always think that the best music for me
again I like all music but for me the
things that really stand the test of
time are things where this sort of
commerce and art come together in this
way right like to me boys of summer by
Don Henley is one of the best songs in
the world because it does this
incredible balance of like you don't
have to tune in to what's going on in
that song to enjoy it but if you decide
you want to sort of like dig in you have
you can I mean the unpack it for days
you have certain lyrics we're gonna
we're gonna talk about some of those in
a bit but I want to dive into some
questions here we have some questions
from our audience about sadness the
first one is from Jessica in Seattle
basically a long and short is the reason
I'm calling is I just I feel like you
guys get me and where I'm at I've gone
through living in a broken home and
abusive relationships and working in
corporate job 19 years almost I just
turned 35 I help take care of my father
trying to live a healthy lifestyle go to
the gym regularly do meal planning for
myself and my father and I'd never have
enough time to step away and remove the
anchors and my job is the biggest thing
to figure out what I want to do with my
life
career-wise I want to find what I'm
passionate about and I don't know how I
get caught up in the whirlwind of the
work week and I'm pulled in so many
directions and just let it happen I was
recently told by a psychic that I'm lazy
when it comes to myself and I got very
man simply was kickboxing 21 days in a
row but I'm not a lazy person and she
said I mean in regards to yourself and
you need to figure out how to not feel
selfish and take the time to figure out
what I'm passionate about and apply
myself towards that because I know if I
take care of myself I can take care of
the people I love around me and yeah I
I'm hoping that you guys can help me
with that mad thoughts that was that was
I mean Jessica in Seattle Jessica sweet
Jessica I haven't you know it's
difficult giving someone feedback on
their life in such a short you know we
just got a burst of her experience but
my first red flag was like she wants to
take care of other people don't take
care of anybody I think if you want I
mean like take care of yourself but it's
like no matter what it's like I get that
humans need each other and I get that
it's your job to and especially family
people want to be able to sort of take
care of family but like it's all about
you can't take care of anybody if you're
not taking care of yourself and if
you're giving all your energy externally
to try and like help people which is
what she said a couple different times
and then also the second red flag was
like take no advice from [ __ ]
psychics it's like it's like or at least
take it with a grain is so Jake it like
yeah if it rings true to you but the
promise is like it's like anything it's
like any peer feedback it's like people
don't know they're just pretty even
psychics I mean they're just projecting
their own experience I guess psychics
aren't in theory but it's like that's a
lot there's a lot of weight oh my god I
wish that she would just shed like
almost all of that like [ __ ] [ __ ] taking
care of other people [ __ ] going to
kickboxing 21 days in a row am I allowed
to say the f-word yeah I just did didn't
I oh my kid like 75 cents right the best
part is Ella my five-year-old daughter
she has a little drop at the beginning
whenever we say bad yeah this podcast is
ours
so yesterday
I was at a bookstore buying a book a
poetry collection I'm not a big poetry
reader but there was it just hit me and
we'll talk about it in a bit but I
walked out with the book in my hand and
this woman walks up to me and she said
where do you get your hair colored more
gee I've never asked that where to get
you the Sun and she goes oh my brother's
been thinking about getting his hair
colored and I was just wondering if you
knew who good plays I'm like no I why
would you say this she goes well anyway
here's my card I'm a psychic and and I
just I've got I've got this if you were
way off I'm let you know I'm gonna throw
this away then for Jessica that the
thing that I will say is I agree with
with what Matt was saying here is with
respect to she's worried about being
selfish and so she tries to give to
everyone else as a result but self-care
is self-interested but it's not selfish
it's actually the opposite because if
you're not taking care of yourself you
don't have anything to give to everyone
else or what you are giving them is
broken and who wants who wants all the
broken pieces yeah yeah we have a real
upside down view of selfishness in our
country and the idea that like it's
self-care is a great way to put it but
it's like you have to be the center of
your universe and you have to treat
yourself with love and respect and
empathy and kindness and you have to
know that you are a limited person on an
ever evolving curve of like soaking in
knowledge and it's like even from just
that little bit like I wish she was here
because I feel like I want to crack open
I feel like she's carrying this all this
weight with her you know forward and
that just makes it life is hard enough
when you have to battle your own brain
but when you then have to sort of ahead
on all these pieces that like make it
feel like you your your backpack is full
of other people's stuff you know I mean
it's like hey but so yeah that well I
think what happens like when we start to
carry all this weight we fall into the
busy trap and that's where Jessica is if
we stay busy coz she's not she's not
lazy she's very very busy but the
problem is if you're not busy about the
right things
well then that is like a perfect recipe
for discontent I mean you know putting
all your energy into other people and
and just constantly worrying about how's
your well-being Matt how's your
well-being Josh
Jordan Shawn how's your well-being in
that and I'm just focused on everyone
else ostensibly like that's a really
good distraction from what's going in
what's going on on the inside but a
distraction is still a distraction yeah
and so I mean she's doing a great job of
distracting herself right now from what
she really needs to deal with and like
the first thing I would I would tell
Jessica is you know you've you've got to
be able to do this sounds kind of like
burn a brownish but like you gotta a
give yourself permission to like to have
some self-care time and you've got to
like give yourself permission to like
feel uncomfortable when you're dealing
with yourself because what happens when
you become alone with yourself you start
to crack open some things that you
didn't really realize that were there
now I think while she's going through
this like uncomfortable time I mean Matt
you mentioned did a lot of therapy I do
therapy every once a while no Josh has
therapy every once in a while it's
really helpful to have someone in the
room that can help unpack all of this
trauma like these traumatic experiences
that Jessica says she's been through
maybe she hasn't dealt with those
perfectly just yet so find someone or
find you know a community of people who
are going to support you I mean that
could be like the Rotary Club
it could be Church it could be what else
Webber and I have a couple other written
down here too um it could be the local
organic farming Association I mean I'm
just trying to bring up random things
because I think when we try to take on
all of this trauma by ourselves it's
very very difficult
so yes finding like a therapist to talk
to you finding a group of people for
support like this is gonna help her
unpack it a little bit more yeah and the
other thing is she said it's like the
brain really only needs to be used like
nine percent of the time and she's
saying I mean this job and I just don't
know my passion is and it's like your
job doesn't have to be your passion do
you don't I mean like your job can
facilitate your passion and you don't
have to it doesn't have to be as hard as
we we make it so hard a lot of the time
and we make like the things that should
just sort of flow through us but we have
these weight and expectation but you
know that were like
my job has to be my passion this has to
be what I love and it's like now dude it
can just make you money and then you can
go yeah you could go for high class
right yeah but also the term find your
passion is is misused because you don't
just stumble across this thing like how
I open the door and there was I found it
no passions are cultivated I someone on
Twitter was asking me about this just
the other day and I'm like you actually
up to cultivate a passion but I can't
find anything I'm good at well you're
bad at everything until you get good at
it you probably pick up the guitar the
hell he probably did he's talented at up
on with the guitar do you believe every
week kind of like I gotta go I don't
know why I gotta go to dance I gotta go
to the art of dance I gotta get rid of
this guitar I only knew three chords
when I was six weeks old that was about
I wish she had been here I felt like
that I felt that there was a lot of
things of like you know we put so much
emphasis on like you have to figure out
who you are and it's like you figure out
who you are when you as you're going and
it evolves and it changes and there's no
set thing you know and it's like we're
we're all just sort of heading towards
hopefully being more wide open and
enlightened than we were when we then
when we were when we started and then we
got kind of slammed shut and so it's
like - she'll figure it out but well I I
feel like with when it comes to passion
we I know I fell into this trap of like
passion equaling happiness and like that
is it's a misnomer because there's a lot
of peaks and there's a lot of valleys
when it comes to chasing a passion and I
think right now Jessica is looking at
all if I could just find what I'm
passionate about then that's gonna fix
all of my problems rid of my sadness but
the truth is is I feel like and if I'm
Way off guys like let me know but I feel
like you've got that she has to do this
self-care first she has to take care of
her problems first before she can really
dive into a passion which again I think
if she did that right now it's just
another distraction well speaking of
problems she said she wants to get rid
of some of the anchors in her life and I
think unfortunately what's what happens
here is she's actually adding anchors on
because I want to start tackling other
people's problems right it's all how you
view it - this is the part that's so
fascinating about humans
is like one person's anchor is another
person sort of wings and it's like if
you decide you if it comes down to the
more bandwidth you can allow yourself to
love yourself and have empathy and
kindness for yourself the more you're
able to see things less as a burden and
more as just what it is which is just
information coming at you that you can
then sort of interpret through your
through your lens and it can be an
anchor if you want it if you create it
to be an anchor it can be something
completely different if you decide to
see it that way and it's like humans
when you're tapped and when you feel
like listening to her even just her
voice you know she and I went to
kickboxing 21 days in a row I'm not lazy
and and it's like it's like Jesus you
don't have any there's no space in there
to breathe there's no space in there to
just be like and because that's the only
way to see things I I think about a lot
when I go on social media and I'll see
people being like it's the end of the
world this is the I mean it is the end
of the world right and it's like dude I
can't live that way you might be able to
and and I don't know if you can or can't
but it's like you got a I don't want to
walk around my whole life believing that
and I also don't want to think I'm an
idiot because I don't believe it which
is the other thing you think it makes
you sharp when you're vigilant and you
see all the all the what you're vigilant
about what's gonna come what's gonna
happen what's gonna happen what's gonna
attack me
within your readying yourself that's
just like no way to live your life you
have no bandwidth for for like the
sweetness in your yeah I was I was
raised Jehovah's Witness and like they
are big like doomsday and of times
they've been they've been screaming the
end of the world since over a hundred
years and it's like I I mean I'm so glad
I got out of it because like now it's
almost like when I was in it I was told
that my life truly hadn't begun yet it's
so like so instead I'm like waiting for
the end of the world so then my life can
truly begin but like when I kind of let
go but it's like as soon as I was able
to let go of like oh like the end of the
world a probably Armageddon as it's you
know written and interpreted through
many religions probably
gonna happen definitely not definitely
but probably not in my lifetime probably
not ever going to happen and once I
accepted that it was like oh now I can
truly kind of play around with life like
I can truly live instead of waiting for
the day when I can start to live yeah if
Armageddon is coming I'm certainly not
gonna be able to stop it by being bummed
about it you know I mean it's like it's
like it's like I wanna [ __ ] I want to
get in the shower and I want to be in
the shower I want to like feel what the
water feels like and I want to be
psyched when I go to bed at night and I
hold my wife I want to hold her and be
focused and be there and be present when
I eat a [ __ ] burrito I want to be
like focused on the burrito I don't want
to be like thinking about how bad
everything is because then it it steals
the joy from and this is the what you're
talking about about this idea that we do
these minutia things that we put in our
way that make us feel like we're
accomplishing things and it doesn't it
all it does is burn us out on the stuff
that matters which is like and this is
super hippy but like the universe and
the flow of energy in the universe and
it's like you can't control any the only
thing you can control is your perception
of things you can't control anything
else it's interesting I think we hold on
to the idea of end times the idea of
it's the end of the world is because
that gives us a feeling of control of
course I mean it's it's it is a control
mechanism but when you do that I mean
you're just you're seeding discontent
you're going to reap discontent well
then you also manifest which is crazy
which I never believed but you manifests
shitty things what do you think shitty
things you manifest beautiful things
when you think beautiful things
yeah it's there's actual phenomena like
if you buy you know a Toyota Corolla
then all of a sudden you start seeing
all the other Toyota Corollas that are
on the road it's the same thing with
with our thoughts and yeah when I hear
from you
I don't know whether or not you meditate
but you're speaking like someone who
does I don't know if I journal I
meditate but I journal which is sort of
meditative yeah yeah and so in terms of
like how we how we interpret the
experience in front of us in fact that
word anchor is interpreted often two
completely different ways like back in
the corporate days people would say Ryan
you're such an anchored person yes I am
look at me I'm so anchored yes
afterward it was like oh man I've got
all these anchors and they're keeping me
from the thing a boat is supposed to do
which is like go out at sea and explore
and be free and so even even there
there's this dichotomy of the anchored
person is also an anchored person
totally yeah I want to give one last
piece of advice to Jessica because you
talked about journaling and how it's a
meditative experience Jessica find a
meditative experience for yourself like
whether it's actually doing a meditation
app I Mariah and I we just started were
on day three it'll be today of the Sam
Harris waking up meditation out yeah
you're right dude like even the first
Josh is like you got to try this
meditation app and I've heard so many
meditation app and they're not horrible
but they're like never have I connected
with one where I'm like this is the one
until Sam Harris is waking up I'm like
oh my god this is the one but whether it
is like doing something like that or
whether it's journaling I mean yeah find
some plain kickboxing but not making it
about exercise yeah that's the other
thing is we take you know exercise in
general is meditative if you can do it
without seeing that there has to be an
end result right like I gotta be fit or
I've got to get this a just like beating
the [ __ ] out of something is incredibly
meditative do you know what I mean like
I and so it's like she could that could
be her meditative place but you it's
about clearing the brain because the
brain sucks and the brain like is
literally like a Gatling gun or like a
sledge hammer like you never use it to
build a house you need it just like for
one very specific problem solving and
it's like but people are like you show
up and you're like how what tools do you
have let's put up this window and
someone's like I've got a sledge hammer
you're like that's where that's not
gonna work and they're like sure it is
and that's just like how it works
jessica.evans send you a copy of our
book essential it's an essay collection
with 150 different essays about
intentional living there's a whole
chapter in there as 12 different
chapters about oh well the 12 chapters
about intentional living but there's one
chapter about priorities and I think
that's one thing that you're gonna have
to figure out what are your real
priorities versus one of the pacifiers
that are in the way Ryan I think we got
time for one lightning round question
what you got for us all right we got one
lightning round question from Michelle
she writes in do you find that you
combat sadness differently as minimalist
well maybe I would say format as a
musician so during a lightning round
this is what we try to do Matt we try to
give apathy less than hundred forty
characters long oh no all right but not
really we just ramble a little bit and
then Sean tweeze is out something that
looks beautiful makes it real nice and
posed yeah we put everything in the show
notes they're called minimal Maksim so
you combat sadness differently as a
musician I mean maybe that's a tool for
for common sense as an artist's you
indulge anyway on a certain level to all
your emotional experiences it's sort of
it's one of the fun parts of being an
artist is that my job is to indulge and
so when sadness shows up all right let's
do this
like let's dig in and and my kid who's
eight does the same thing and I think I
think you know she has an artistic she
feels things in a very big way but but
what was the question yeah yeah Michelle
so living in it I mean being asked to
you made of are you are you combating
sadness differently as a creative you
think a lot of other people do no
because you're because you're able to
sort of sit with it I think other people
maybe that's the takeaway here is as
opposed to distracting ourselves which i
think is what yeah I think that's part
of it doesn't mean you have to continue
to suffer and and hold on to the sadness
this is what you're saying is like it's
the idea of this you're experiencing
what you're experiencing so if I drop a
brick on my penis that's gonna hurt I
still could like it but it would hurt so
I do that and then but if in a week from
now I decide to relive what it felt like
to drop a brick on my penis I'm wasting
my time yeah I mean I just want to drop
it on there feel it and be like this is
what it feels like to drop a brick on my
penis does it hurt am i sad do I want to
cry and then you move through it but if
I'd be an [ __ ] if every day of my
life I relived dropping a brick on my
penis yeah because it would gobble up my
entire two ways it's a waste of your
life and so sadness and happiness are
the same thing you have to be in it and
if something makes you sad experience it
and then move through it if something
makes you happy experience it and then
move through it and then experience what
the universe wants to give you as
opposed to the stuff
dragging forward from the stuff that has
happened yes I love them we just found
our trailer for this episode
dude sat to me like sadness is
inevitable like it's not about avoiding
sadness it's about well I mean like
here's a pithy answer I got written down
it's if we live overwhelming lives it
doesn't take much for us to feel like
we've lost control so you know whether
it being a minimalist or a musician if
you're living an overwhelming life even
happiness might overwhelm you when it
comes at you when you're not ready for
it or if you're not prepared to deal
with a large emotion like that but you
know this idea of how do you you know
how do you avoid sadness like that's
that's impossible
like I you know I hate to say it but one
day you're gonna die man I hope it's
hope it's all dying yeah I hope it is
that I hope it's yeah it's true like I
hope it's after I die but if I got a
witness to death it's gonna be really
really sad man and it's not a it's not
about trying to avoid sadness as a whole
it's it's how am i living my life now so
when these things happen
how can I process it but it can also be
awesome when he dies and I don't mean
the Senate like I'm saying like cuz you
guys drama buddies and it's like you
love him and it's an opportunity for you
to like indulge in there's a very acute
feeling when someone passes where where
and you don't get it any other way and
all of a sudden you just feel this
unbelievable sense of like love and
connection to this person and you're so
[ __ ] grateful that they existed and
all of a sudden the world for however
long it lasts the the roof of the world
cracks open and you just feel this
incredible thing so it's like and it's
in conjunction with what it can be in
conjunction with anger it can be in
conjunction with sadness it can be all
that stuff this is the thing is like all
that we can't be afraid of those
experiences because that is the one
thing that we've got is like to be able
to take on all those things to be
resilient enough to do it and to be able
to like experience every dynamic part of
it yeah like it's the beautiful beauty
of being a human it's the beauty of the
brain because animals don't you know
it's like it's the the brain is a tool
that gets used very very not very often
but it is that
thing that allows us to feel things on
this dynamic level and we're cheating
ourselves if we don't yeah I feel like
we're often bludgeoning ourselves with
with our own brains you know and I've
learned this especially through
meditation it just realizing that
everything here is just sort of
appearing every emotion is is appearing
and it's gotten to a point where you can
sit with it you can sit with the sadness
you can sit like you said you talked
about being overwhelmed by happiness
like that is a thing Tennessee Williams
wrote wrote an essay called the
catastrophe of success I think that's
what it was called yeah and what it
reminds me of is that you know we we
often get what we want before we started
recording actually we were we were
talking about like the venues that we've
played in and I say us play we haven't
we don't play instruments yeah but and
Matt you know you'll go to places that
are truly iconic places but they're
iconic because they're sort of this
piece of mythology we've all
collectively as a society turned it into
this where we put it on a pedestal
because it has a particular name if you
change the name of Madison Square Garden
and moved it to States over moved to
Connecticut or something and it was the
same venue but it was brand-new you'd be
like wait a minute this is this is a
different thing because it's just wood
and steel and it's like and but that's
also what's so freeing about it it's
like you can it can be whatever you want
it to be like you can go in there and
feel it as if it I can't believe you to
did like I can't believe Billy Joel does
eight night what I'm standing in the
spot where probably bono stood during
the you know you can do that and that's
that you can bring that to that or you
can go in and you can be like this is
there's nothing attached to this place
this is just a stage I'm gonna own this
and I'm gonna make this mine and then
you can do that or you can go in and be
like what a [ __ ] these people are
[ __ ] and it's like all of that is
totally wide open to you and and then
your experience is then based on
whatever combination of those things you
want to do and most people believe we've
been taught in a very strange way by
consumerism and all this capitalism and
is that if you're not feeling put upon
you're not doing it right if you're not
feeling the weight of your day if you're
not feeling the frustration of your
traffic like you're not doing it right
and like traffic can be [ __ ] awesome
yeah you know what I mean like you it if
you plan and you realize that you your
bandwidth gives you if you give yourself
space everything is really [ __ ]
awesome
yeah like it just is and I'm not a
positive person I'm not a happy I mean I
came from the like sub unhappy on a
level that I don't think you know like
we've probably all experienced but like
the banana chooses unhappy
yeah that is generations of started
pushing the British out of Lexington and
then being then watching our you know
and being like I'm gonna be unhappy for
about 300 years but yeah and so anyway
but but that's it that's really the
that's is not very pithy but that's the
that's the no it's it's I totally agree
man it's like perception is everything
it's funny like growing up I always
heard we create our own reality I looked
at it as like a hippie dippie type of
saying but it's the truth man it's like
everything you said about Madison Square
Gardens is true yeah you get to choose
like what story you tell yourself and it
doesn't and the other thing is that if
you decide to look at it as [ __ ]
because you're a little bit sick or you
haven't eaten your blood sugars in a
certain way you have an exercise you
haven't stretched your hip flexors and
it's hurting then that's okay too like
you're allowed to go into Madison Square
Garden and be pissed that the [ __ ]
loaders don't talk to you like you're
allowed to feel all of that and it's
like but what are you gonna do in your
routine during the day that's gonna set
you up for success the best way it can
if it means getting up exercising eating
food journaling you these are the things
you control you can create a set of
habits you guys have talked about this
but a set set of habits that allow you
to set yourself up for as much success
as you can I know if I don't have
breakfast I know if I don't exercise
that like after a certain amount of time
like nothing is good and so it's like
everyday you just have to sort of know
yourself enough and critically think
enough to set up a
just a few simple things that make you
feel like okay I can handle I can bring
it on I've got it I've got the bandwidth
I'm ready to ride the rollercoaster of
this day wherever it's gonna take me and
sometimes I'll fall off and want to
punch somebody at Starbucks and
sometimes I'll be like I love this
person like how rad is it that that kid
in that adult are talking and how great
is it that humans get to be together in
this life and you can teach people and
there's this exchange of energy all that
stuff happens man yeah absolutely the
thing that really stood out to me he
said you're allowed to feel that you
allowed you're allowed to feel just
angry at the world but also you don't
have to I think is ultimately what the
message that that you're communicating
here it's like yeah you can you can
experience it but you don't have to
cling to it and sometimes we cling to it
and then that that leads to the road
rage in traffic war it becomes our
identity which is the other thing right
you've talked about this as well I'm the
anxious person yes I'm I'm the guy that
likes to snap I get pissed off on B I'm
that guy from boss and like my wife
doesn't let me drive like she does not
let me drive my kid wrote to Santa Claus
on the note dear Santa I said put some
stuff that you're psyched on to you
can't just ask for [ __ ] and she's like
I'm grateful that my mother drives and
my dad doesn't cuz he's terrible
I was like dude I was like well done I
said I said Santa Fe zani if he's in it
all he's gonna know exactly where you're
like you can't let your identity be that
thing and it's like and you also have to
allow yourself if you want to be in your
car yelling about something this is the
other problem with humans and I'm sorry
to keep rambling but this idea that we
live in a time where everybody feels
explosive and everybody feels like their
opinion needs to be heard on so if I'm
having an experience you have to
someone's 15 people are gonna tell me
their interpret how they feel about my
experience they're gonna either validate
or invalidate my experience which is
something I don't want anybody to
[ __ ] do I don't give a [ __ ] how much
what you think about anything if I tell
you something about myself and I share
it with you and then you have to then
tell me project on to me and push down
how I feel it's like go [ __ ] yourself I
don't care what you think about how I
feel but here's the deal you have to
allow yourself moments in the day to
indulge in go [ __ ] yourself like like if
you want to be in your car and you want
to be mad about something
but not but you're not hurting other
people and you're not hurting yourself
but you have to be able to give yourself
that exercise of being like screaming at
the television if for twenty minutes if
you feel like you want to be so mad that
the president United States has no
empathy and kindness and you want to
like yell at the TV about it like that's
healthy you should be able to do that
but then getting on on instruct on like
Facebook for three hours and telling
people have shitty they are it's like
that is not a good use of your time nor
is it something that's gonna do anything
other than feed that habit in a in a bad
way
yeah and I definitely talk about how
social media leads to sadness we have a
bunch more surprise questions here about
becoming an overnight success and Matt
you did that hour after 15 years no yeah
about dealing with despair loss and
sadness I've got 21 ways to deal with
sadness apparently we're gonna we're
gonna break this down and I'm gonna see
I questioned some of these 21 ways and I
want to see what your guys's take are on
all 21 ways we've got a question about
being too busy to appreciate the little
victories see what I did that yeah also
I want to talk to Matt about sort of not
the conventional hey what inspired you
is living in San Francisco yeah we're
not gonna do that but I do want to talk
about some of your lyrics and and I
don't want you to explain lyrics because
that's like explaining jokes but what
I'm gonna do is is maybe unpack them a
little bit and see what I what I see
happening to the right of the frame the
worst as well I like asking musician
about their lyrics and it has nothing to
do with what I thought they were about
and it just ruins it for me so I don't
ask you know I don't try not to tell
because it's like you wanna it's your
thing it's like you the song is yours
yeah it's the the Jason Mraz thing right
I wrote the song about my cat and I it
was like this deep love song that you
and I together in this life the whole
thing and we're gonna talk about how
social media leads to sadness as well so
a bunch of things to talk about and if
you want to hear all that you can listen
to this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different long-form
maximal episode over on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the
private space
we need to talk about a whole bunch of
topics that we don't usually discuss in
public plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast and keep it 100
percent advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app you'll also get access to our entire
back catalogue of more than 100 private
podcast episodes you can find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional private podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists com
slash support Ryan what else you got for
us this week being informed is more
important than ever these days so I just
want to encourage everyone to read more
and get informed and now here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners hi this is scott from kansas
city listening to the podcast on hope
and your caller john who called and said
he gotten into minimalism and yet had
not experienced the joy well I would
suggest minimalism has nothing to do
with stuff minimalism is the first step
in an unconscious rejection of the
social contract that says stuff is the
answer
stuff that the answer of sell at the
expense of self at the expense of
identity at the expense of dreams
so what Jon needs to do is recognize
that stuff getting rid of stuff only
clears the deck and now he's free to put
in the work to discover what he values
what he hopes for the real goal is to
discover yourself
my name is Susan and I recently listened
to your donations episode and I just
want to say that I work at a goodwill as
a job coach in the donation centers with
adults of disabilities and I super love
my job I love every I love going to work
every single day and I love the people I
work with well one thing I've noticed
about a lot of donors don't know about
is that while goodwill has like
thousands of locations all across the
nation every goodwill is run locally and
specializes in different local issues so
the goodwill in my town we specialize in
domestic violence victims and people
with autism by the next big city in in
my state they specialize with a lot of
homeless populations and a lot of at
risk youth so that's something that I
would just recommend that everybody to
like really look into your goodwill like
your local goodwill because you can
really see on how they create a lot of
local change and you can get involved in
that to you all right Joe thanks again
to Matt Nathanson for joining us today
make sure you check out his new album
sings his sad heart and real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalists we're taking a break from
touring
right now although ryan and i we did a
tour stop this year well sort of with a
friend Colin and kudos to Jordan Jordan
filmed an amazing event and Colin's talk
was unbelievable that's great yeah we
just released it for our true fans on
patreon so there's a group of people on
patreon who are like this true fan tier
and you get access to all of our live
events so even if you can't attend the
live event will have either audio or
video recordings where they allow and
Jordan did an amazing job Sean did a
great job with the audio as well so you
can check that out over on patreon
it's Colin's talk and then we have a
second video which is the three of us me
and Ryan and Colin and we did a Q&A with
the audience so you'll be able to check
that out so we're not touring for a
while right now we're working on some
stuff but if you'd like to see us live
or at least live on your screen that's
one way for you to do it give
comment or minimalism tip for a podcast
leave us voicemail four zero six two one
nine seven eight three nine or send a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our e-mail list over at the
minimalists comm you'll also receive our
simple Sunday emails each week for our
added value this week let's listen to my
favorite Matt Nathanson so on I think
it's my favorite it's my favorite today
at least it's the only song that's there
are two songs that have ever made me cry
one was this song we're about to play
it's it's called Bill Murray there's got
to be some irony in that somewhere it's
such a good song and it made me cry
because I looked over at Becks we were
listened to in the car and it's about
like finding sort of love of your life
or I won't run it just listen to the
song it's so so good this has nothing to
do with the song but there is a group of
people who get together and they just
tell stories about how they've run into
Bill Murray in public I think it's an LA
of course it would be in LA but like
it's like 2030 people he was like South
Carolina or something though that dude
it's wild like it's like 2030 people
they get together and they literally
just talk about instances were met or
ran into Bill Murray this is a beautiful
song it's called Bill Murray by Matt
Nathanson if you leave here today with
just one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
minimus